مع حلول الالفيه الثانيه في موزمبيق حيث
يعيش غالبيه السكان الذين يقل دخلهم عن
دولار واحد يوميا في اكواخ لم يكن ينقص
الناس هنا الا كارثه طبيعيه فبعد سلسله
فيضانات عارمه ضربت البلاد حدث ما لم يكن
في الحسبان فما القصه خلال الفتره من
الرابع حتى السابع من فبراير ضرب الاعصار
كاني الساحل الجنوبيه الشرقي لموزمبيق
وتلقت مقاطعه الساحليه ما يقرب من 18 بوصه
من الامطار في اعقاب كاني جاء اعصار ايلين
وتلاته عاصفه استوائيه شديده تسببت بفيضان
نهر اللمبوبو
تعرضت موزمبيق لاعلى موجات هطول مطري
وامتدت التاثيرات للدول المحيطه
كسوازيلاند وبوتسوانا ومدغشقر وجنوب
افريقيا وزامبيا وزيمبابوي
ضربت المنطقه سلسله من موجات الفيضانات
الهائجه في بعض الاحيان وصل ارتفاعها الى
86 قدما فتدفقت المياه الجاريه بين
الوديان والاراضي السهليه وايضا بين مساكن
الناس واجبر الناس على مغادره منازلهم كما
اضطر للصعود على الاسطح والاشجار استمر
هطول الامطار في البلاد لاسابيع وتقطعت
السبل بالعديد من العائلات دون طعام او
مياه نظيفه فمات العديد منهم بسبب الجوع
حاول عمال الاغاثه انقاذ الالاف من ضحايا
الفيضانات واستخدمت في عمليات الانقاذ
السفن البحريه والطائرات المروحيه حيث تم
انقاذ اكثر من 45 الف شخص عن طريق الجو
تسببت الفيضانات في مقتل اكثر من 800 شخص
واصابه الالاف كما شردت اكثر من 650 الفا
في جميع انحاء جنوب افريقيا
دمرت منازل نحو 800 الف الى مليون شخص وتم
ايواء النازحين في مخيمات وملاج اضافه
للمنشات الكبيره كالمدارس والمصانع كما
تعرضت العديد من المستشفيات والعيادات
لاضرار جسيمه وعانت من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي غمرت المياه الاراضي الزراعيه
والمحاصيل التي تعتمد عليها القرى للبقاء
على قيد الحياه وتعطلت انظمه الري ونفقت
الماشيه ما ادى الى دمار اكثر من 62,6
اسره زراعيه مع حلول مارس بدات المياه
تتراجع ببطء الى جميع الانهار الرئيسيه في
جنوب موزمبيق واعيد فتح بعض الطرق
الرئيسيه في البلاد وبدات عمليه توزيع
المساعدات بالشاحنات في بلد يعد من الافقر
في العالم تطلب الامر 450 مليون دولار
لاعاده بناء ما امكن فيما بقي الكثيرون
يعانون من تبعاته لسنوات عديده قادمه لم
تخلو من الكوارث والويلات
[موسيقى]